hello everybody um i'd first like to say
thank you for uh coming to this session
and i hope that um yeah everybody's
having fun up by data so far and
learning a lot of interesting things and
i hope that today uh yeah people have
hopefully learned something new from my
session
so
my session today is going to have quite
a operations research type flavor to it
i'll go into that in a little bit more
detail in a few slides time
but yeah it's mostly around what we call
linear programming which is
one of the oldest most well
well studied techniques for solving
optimization problems in businesses and
in
even academic settings too
so my sessions you're going to be
focused around that and some of the
tools that i've used in the past few
years to um to solve these problems
so
before we move on i'll just give you a
little bit of the background to myself
and hopefully give you a little bit of
motivation as to why i want to deliver
this session today and what
i want everybody to be able to get out
of it
so
i work for tesco who are a large
supermarket chain primarily based in the
united kingdom
um and we have uh yeah a huge number of
stores
and
part of
running our business is being able to um
run things optimally um and being able
to solve optimization problems very
quickly is really key to most big
businesses really
and
yeah our data science team has grown
over the past few years
and we cover things
from all sides of the business from the
workforce in our business to
i'm actually more customer-facing things
but we also have um part of our business
as well is really focused on things like
transport and fulfillment which is where
really you need to start making optimal
decisions to be able to
to be able to make
the business run as efficiently as
possible
for this reason we actually have an
embedded operations research team
um here at tesco um but i'm not one of
the um one of the expert members of that
team as such but i have gained an
interest in the techniques and tools
they use over the past few years
so yeah just to give you a little bit of
a rundown of my own
background before we go into
going to the rest of the presentation
so as i've just mentioned i'm a senior
data scientist at tesco
and but my formal background is in
astrophysics and that has already been
mentioned earlier so the key thing here
is that i don't really have a formal
training in operations research
everything i've learned has been
from my own
self-study and my own um yeah
studying things and trying to solve
things myself
in the past couple of years so
up until two years ago i didn't even
know what linear programming was or what
or how to solve one of these things and
where they would be applicable
um but
my interest really started when um at my
previous employer um there was a need
that was coming in for
um to for us to be able to solve um
optimization problems in our business
particularly around things like
workforce so getting the right number of
staff members in to
um to cover the jobs we needed to do and
things like this and
at my old job we didn't really have an a
formal operations research team there at
that time so
a lot of the um optimization work was
falling on the data science team who was
um who was already in that business and
yeah it was at that point i decided to
start learning about different
optimization techniques and how to solve
mathematical optimization problems
and it's really there where my own
interest really sparked and where i
um really started to learn about
interesting things and one of the things
i did learn about was something called
linear programming
so my main aim for today's session
really is that um
for me i think being able to solve
optimization problems is a really
interesting tool for a data scientist to
have
outside of the typical things you see in
things like
machine learning um and classification
and things like this these more sort of
typical um problems um but
you know a lot of problems in particular
since i've been at tesco actually come
with a prediction and an optimization
element to them and being able to solve
the optimization part as well as just
being able to make good predictions
really may potentially can make you as a
data scientist a really valuable member
of a team and can make you
yeah just expand the variety of problems
that you can actually solve
using data
so
before i go into the main
technical part of today's talk i would
just like to say it's that
because i'm not
somebody with a lot of formal training
in this i've aimed this session very
much at people like me a couple of years
ago it's for people who've never really
seen a um optimization problem before or
certainly haven't seen it very much
and certainly people who've never seen a
linear program so
for this reason um
the sessions been put together so that
you only really need three things to
really be able to get the most out of
this session
firstly you need just to be able to use
python and jupyter notebooks in
particular which is
my my own um
my own preferred tools for um solving
these problems in particular
python
secondly to be able to install or tools
which can be installed via pip
on a local machine and finally just to
be able to see um to be able to see some
examples that i've got um in this or2
tools tutorial which i've put on github
for today so hopefully everyone can have
access to them and again i'm trying to
make this session as flexible as
possible so
the way i'm gonna structure it is it
will mostly be me um talking and then
going through some examples in some
notebooks
but um
if people think that they they already
know a lot of the concepts here and they
want to start doing more complex things
there's a notebook with some problems in
which are slightly more where there's
particularly quite a complex one at the
end which
um you know so if you feel like you want
to go ahead and do that you can if you
want or if you're very new to this and
you don't think you're not quite
comfortable to be able to solve these
yet you can also just watch me go
through a notebook and solve problems as
well so it's totally up to you how you
want to do this
how um far ahead you want to get in
terms of the material i'm talking about
again
anybody who doesn't have his name
could you cross it out
that's really cute i don't
forgot that we even existed
what was that sorry
i'm sorry stephen uh are you asking a
question
oh these are weird now
sorry yeah
yeah so really just to conclude this
slide really there's three things i want
people to get out of today's session
firstly i want people to be able to
understand what a linear program or a
mixed integer linear program is and
potentially in their own work be able to
identify when one of these problems
might happen
and when
these solutions i'm talking about today
might be applicable the second part i
want people to do is be able to solve
one of these problems on paper so this
is a mathematical programming really so
be able to formulate one of these on
paper
and finally see some of the tools that
i've gained some experience in and to
solve these problems actually in machine
code and get a solution out so therefore
complete the whole end-to-end cycle of
identifying
identifying a linear program and being
able to write it out and then being able
to solve it
so that's the end of the sort of the
main introductory part but now i'm going
to go into first the first real
technical part of the talk which is a
little bit of background into linear
programming and what linear programming
is
and also what operations research is as
well i guess is a more broad scale
so
in um optimization what we're typically
concerned in concerned about are often
things called combinatorial optimization
problems
so these are problems where there's um a
set of different x values
um or they could be labeled any
value you want really but
to find what the optimal set of these
different x values is in a
from a set of feasible solutions
now these are very well studied and
the biggest
problem with them in a sense is that as
soon as you start including several
variables and
lots of different options that these
variables can take in terms of values
these problems basically they grow
exponentially and they can
take a huge amount of time to solve and
look through all of the possible options
and to find the optimal solution so very
very quickly actually only with a few
variables really these problems become
too difficult to solve
quickly
if you don't if you want if you want to
go through every possible solution and
find the one that is the best
so linear programs are a similar flavor
of to this but they are but the
difference is they're not concerned with
problems that are found within a
set of values so it's not like
examples where x is in 0 1 2 3 4 or
something like this
instead this is concerned with finding
the optimal
um solution to the the best value of x
given um
a contin um a continuous range that it
can possibly take
but the key thing here is that both of
these types of problems can take a huge
amount of time to solve
but actually
what's quite interesting about these
optimization problems is that they are
really well studied and
actually solutions to these problems in
particular one i'm going to talk about
today's what's called the simplex
algorithm
were developed actually
quite a long time ago compared to most
advances in data science
so these were developed in actually the
first sort of working algorithm to solve
these kind of problems these linear
programs was actually developed in the
1940s by this guy here called george
danzig
and
he was basically trying to solve a
problem about staffing actually quite
similar to the one in my previous job
where
um yeah trying to work out what the
optimum number of people to have in
different roles um would be
but it's yeah these optimization
problems have a really interesting
history because
the algorithms for solving these things
have been written down for
quite a while again back to the 1940s
really but
it's only sort of the past 10 20 years
or so that we've started to have the
computational power to actually solve
them really efficiently
so
even though the
mathematical formulations are quite old
the um
computational power to actually get good
solutions quickly which hopefully i'll
be talking about today and we'll give
you some examples today already now is
actually a time where we're really
starting to get good solutions to a lot
of big interesting business problems
so before i move on um i just want to
introduce what a linear program is and
the reason i am
going to introduce it is that they have
a very very specific form to them
so a linear program is typically
concerned with finding
the values of
different x values effectively in these
continuous sets i mentioned earlier so
in this case it could be x1 x2 x3 all
the way to x n
the next thing is you usually
you are trying to find a
optimal objective function
so that's the second line here so we've
got this find x1 x2 or later xn that
maximizes an objective function that is
um c1 times x1 plus c2 times x2 all the
way to cm times xn
so
the key thing here is that these
objective functions have to be
linear for you to have a linear program
hence the name
and so
these c values here
are
constants effectively they don't change
and then the next thing that defines a
linear program is you then have a set of
constraints which are actually quite
similar to that linear objective
function
in that they're constants multiplied by
the x values
and then you add them all up and then
you're usually subject to some kind of
constraint this could be a capacity
constraint of some kind usually or
they can also come across in quite a few
different ways really it could be these
can be them you need to make more than
this number of units or you're limited
to to creating this many units or
something similar to this
but again the key thing to point out
here is that everything here is linear
so all of these both the objective
function and every constraint we have
has to be linear if not then we can't
use linear programming to solve these
problems
and
that you have to use something slightly
more complicated but
for today's session we're going to be
focusing very much on um programs that
are very similar to
of that i've set up in this exact way
now because one thing to point out here
is that these are very very specific
cases here that we're talking about um
they have to be set up in this exact way
and as i've just mentioned anything that
differs from this if you had a quadratic
expression or something like this
would mean that we um
would mean that we don't we can't use
linear programming so if we've got a
very explicit um
problem like this that has to be
formulated in a very
um a very
uh
sorry word
a very
um
exact way like this one of the
things that i like to do and i've been
told to do is to
try and formulate all these problems in
a similar way and go through a six or
seven step process to
solving these problems so
if you are in a business for example and
you get given a problem that potentially
might fit this linear programming style
then the first thing that um
that
i've always been told to do is to just
write it down yourself so describe the
rules which are the constraints
and the objective function verbally so
the reason we do this is that
it can help us to understand whether a
make sure we've got a linear program
there's not any non-linearities
and secondly it can help us to just
really get to grips with the problem and
see what the different parts of the
problem are
and really understand it before we
actually just write start writing down
on any maths
the next thing we should do is then
describe the basic entities of the
problem sets so i'm going to go through
an example in the next couple of slides
that'll hopefully
add a bit of um
a bit of detail to what these things are
and give people an example of what we're
talking about but entities are usually
um effectively they're just sort of
parts of the problem really they could
be different
products that your factory manufacturers
they could be different days of the week
they can be things like this effectively
the next thing is to describe any
related parameters the problem assets
using the entities we um have before so
this is effectively defining these
constants these c values on the right
hand side of the screen and these a
values
um the next thing is then actually only
after you've done those three things is
you start to actually write the
mathematical formulation for the problem
that you're going to solve
so the first thing we do is we define
the decision variables and these are
your x variables so a decision variable
is so named because
it's a variable which can take multiple
values and we're making a decision over
which one of them
and what value x should take in order to
have the
most optimal value
then we write down the objective
function using everything we've just
seen these constants that we've already
described these parameters and also the
decision variables before finally moving
on to the constraints of the problem so
steps four five and six is where we go
through and do those three lines the
find part the maximizes part and the
subject to part of the linear program on
the right hand side of the screen
then the reason why it's sometimes a
seven step process is sometimes you have
to iterate this sometimes there's
something you missed in the problem so
just iterate until you feel you're happy
that you've covered everything
that needs to be covered and that you've
built your program up
so that's all kind of abstract at the
moment but
i put together a exam an example that um
hopefully should illustrate some of the
points i've just talked about here
and i chose this example mostly because
it's
first of all it's only in two dimensions
which is really helpful because that
means we can plot it up on a graph and
see what and see what the results might
look like
and secondly it's you know seems to be
somewhat physically motivated albeit
it's very very simplified
so i'm just going to read through the
problem statement now
so we've got our crest company makes two
products there's a premium product and
the other one is a standard product
and they supply these to a supermarket
it takes two hours factory time to make
one of the premium products
um and it takes um only in one and a
half hours to make one the standard ones
but the profit you get from each of them
is different you get 200 pound profit
from the premium and 125 pounds from the
uh from the standard product
so the factory is open 40 hours per week
and we have a client who already has a
weekly order of 10 standard units that
we need to fulfill the rest of the
factory time is free to be used
how we see fit so the question is how
many boxes of each type should we make
each week
so
a lot of people probably can already
hopefully see what the solution to this
might be but we're going to go through
it mathematically
and demonstrate exactly what's happening
in linear programming by doing that
so let's go through this six stage
process the first one i'm going to do is
just describe the constraints and the
objectives that we have so the first one
is that the total production time must
not exceed 40 hours
we must produce 10 units of the standard
product per week
and the objective is simply to just
maximize profits in this case it's a
very simple objective function
so now i'm going to talk about these
entities and in this case
it's quite a simple one the entities we
have are
effectively the two different types of
product
so i'll label them as s and p for
standard or premium
then we use those entities to define
some parameters of the problem which are
these constants that
that stay the same
so we have
effectively we're going to have four
parameters in this problem we're going
to have two for the
amount of time it takes to make one box
of these crisps and then there's going
to be two for the profit margins so
they're i'm going to label them as t
and there's p so we can keep track of
those and i'm going to use subscripts in
this case so that we can
yeah know which
of the products they refer to so we're
using these entities to
um yeah to create these parameters
you then define your decision variables
which
in this case again it's relatively
simple it's just how much of each item
should i be making
now the objective function is
is relatively simple again here it's
we want to maximize this the profit so
that's p is the profit margin per unit
that we make
and y is the amount of units that we
make and the key thing here is that we
can immediately see that the objective
function is linear
so what we can see here is that the um
what we've got is these constant p
values multiplied by these decision
variables there's no nonlinearities here
which tells us that
linear programming can be applied to
this problem
and finally let's talk about the
constraints
so we have this pre-existing customer
order that we've already discussed and
that one and that means that we have to
make at least 10 of the standard unit
and we can't make any negative
quantities because that's completely
infeasible in real life so that means
that
the other products all have to be um
greater than or equal to zero
and then the final thing is we have a
production limit which again we can see
and it's very similar to the objective
function but we can see that it's um
also linear it's the time to make each
product multiplied by the amount of
products that we make
and again that's got to be capped at 40
because that's the number of hours that
our factory is open for
so we can see here is we have a linear
program everything is linear
and we can put this into a solver and
get the um optimal solution out but
before we do that i'm just going to
i'm just going to briefly mention um
that
what this solution looks like on paper
so what we can do is we can actually
draw this up because we've only got two
dimensions and it's a very simple
problem so what we have is we have this
vertical line here which
is at 10 which basically tells us that
we can't use and we can't
make any less than the 10 units that
we've been asked to make the standard
product
the
blue line that's diagonal is effectively
constraining our factory production
limit
and
the um red lines show lines of constant
objective value so in the bottom left we
have a thousand pounds then it's two
thousand pounds three thousand pounds
four thousand pounds
and just by playing this up on paper we
can see that the um optimal objective
value is going to be right in the corner
here it's going to be
to um
make the 10 standard units and spend the
rest of the time making
making the premium product which
actually a lot of people probably
may have seen when we did the problem
statement makes a lot of sense because
the profit per unit time of making those
products is
um
is much greater in that case so it makes
sense to spend the rest of the time
making the
product that has the most profit per
unit time
so our optimal objective value is right
in the corner now this was a simple
problem but this is something that's
really really key in linear programming
is that the
even though this is a simple problem no
matter how complex your problem gets the
optimal solution value is mathematically
proven to always be
one of the vertices of your search space
so this is how the simplex algorithm
does its work effectively is
it's not concerned with this blue shaded
region no matter how complicated your
problem gets what it will do is it will
search through the vertices of your
feasible region
and find the optimal vertex and that
will that is proven to be the optimal
value of the whole problem
so that is why the simplex algorithm is
so fast and why it
is just so widely used and there are
variations of it and improvements have
been made to it but this is really the
key to linear programming is
if you have all of your constraints and
your objective are all linear no matter
how many of them there are then
the um feasible solution is always at a
vertex of the
search space
so that is how the simplex algorithm
works in a nutshell
so what we've seen so far is we've seen
a linear program and we've
written it down on paper
so now let's
talk a little bit about how we might
as data scientists actually
find a solution to this problem because
it's okay being able to write it out on
paper but if we had a more complex one
which we couldn't actually draw it out
how would we actually find a solution
so i'm going to go through
some of the popular tools that can be
used for linear programming in python
so the way this usually works is there's
usually a
wrapper effectively which are these um
top three modules i mentioned here so
some common ones include
pyomo pulp and ortools so i've never
developed any of these tools and so if
anybody prefers any over the other i
don't mind but
our tools is one that i
tend to use just because i like the
syntax of it i think the syntax is quite
pythonic for me
and also it seems to be very well
maintained and have good documentation
now it's a tool that's developed by
google but
it is an open source
tool that you can use to solve problems
but what these wrappers are usually
doing is they are
[Music]
interfacing to a
back-end solver which is usually
developed by somebody else
and
um
there are quite a few of them out there
some common ones you may see if you do
some um googling of common um tools in
python to solve these problems are
listed here now i've highlighted cbc
because this is just one that i've used
quite a lot in the past and it seems to
give me good results and solve problems
quite quickly
but there are others called and things
like glpk and the last two on this list
here are called gorobian cplex which
actually are very very fast but the
problem with them is is that these are
um
these are commercially licensed products
so
one of the things with linear
programming and
these optimization problems that often
people find is that because it's a much
older
field of study than a lot of machine
learning there's not so much of an open
source community and the best solvers
are actually paid for
but
from my own experience i can say that
i've been able to solve a lot of
problems at tesco
using a a set of open source solvers and
including cbc that i've highlighted here
so yes the best solvers
are commercially licensed but there are
free solvers out there and they are
actually very good and they can still
find solutions to problems very very
quickly
but before we move on to actually
writing some code which i'm going to do
in a few moments time i've just put on
the right hand side here the
typical syntax you'll see with our tools
as you can see i quite like the syntax
it's very very simple
and everything you need really is on the
right hand side of the screen you can
set up us over very quickly
and you can set up variables using the
solver.numbar and solver.interval
and set lower bounds and upper bounds
accordingly
and then the objective again is really
simple to write out you just write
either solver.maximize or it on minimize
and um yeah finally adding linear
straight constraints is just you done
using the solver dot add functionality
but that's sort of the end of the first
sort of technical introduction part of
this and
if there are any questions is probably
the first moment we have to
talk about them but if not i will move
on to actually writing some code will be
the next part of this tutorial
uh we do have some questions russ yeah
so my question is um can you give or is
it possible to give a general uh big o
estimate of the complexity of let's say
combinatorial problem
um in terms of the number of constraints
number of variables for example if i
want to get a rough estimate of okay i
know it takes certain time to solve my
problem with
two categories of crisps
how would it be with four categories
uh yeah so
it is possible to do that actually um
but it depends on sort it's the
complexity of the problem but um or
effectively how many um
categories of things you have but
typically these things scale
exponentially
particularly in the combinatorial case
because each variable you add in
what you're going to do is you're going
to
basically have one extra decision to
make
which can have multiple possible values
so if i introduce a new category and it
has
two items to it then that means that
uh effectively you've
doubled your possible search space and
so then each time you introduce one it
effectively works like that
but
yeah it's um it really depends on the
um
possible values that you can have i
think so
yeah
sorry i didn't really answer that
particularly well but
generally yes increasing the number of
variables is
just means that for every possible value
of that variable
you increase the problem size by that
amount effectively
thank you thank you very much
apologies for dropping off i guess mine
was unstable
anyway we have another question and this
is by deepak he asked how do you check
if your objective should be linear
beforehand
so this is
this is the art of linear programming
is
usually what you have to this is if i go
back actually to this slide this is why
we
start by typically describing the rules
and the constraints of the objective
function verbally
so um
[Music]
what will typically happen is you'll be
able to write out your problem and say
these are the entities and these are the
parameters that are involved
and it's actually by going through this
six stage process that you find out
whether there are any non-linearities or
not and it's at that point that you
decide whether i should proceed with
linear programming or use something else
so yeah it's purely in the process of
taking the problem on paper to um
the mathematics um that
that you work out so you can't really
tell that at the very start if it's a
huge complex problem and i've certainly
been in situations where i've worked out
after a few hours or so that isn't
linear for whatever reason but
it's yeah it's the process of turning
the paper stuff into the maths that you
work that information out
i hope that answers the question um yeah
he says thank you
so we do not have any other questions at
the moment
cool so i guess now is the time for me
to start writing some code so again um
the github link that i had at the start
um
actually i could put it in the chat
couldn't i um if people want to download
the um project
is um
i put the github link in the chat oh
perfect thank you very much um
um yeah
effectively is a um
is a
um going to be a folder where there's
going to be some problems and some
lecture problems i'm going to be mostly
talking through the lecture problems
today but there's also a much more open
problem in the problems
notebook as well
so let's open a notebook and let's start
working through one of these linear
programs and
hopefully here you'll
this will hopefully
improve people's understandings a little
bit because we're going to kind of
reiterate everything we've just gone
through
and also hopefully people will see how i
tend to structure my code to make this
as
easy to follow as possible
so the first thing we
have to do is we have to
we have to import our
solver
um and to use the cbc backend to find a
solution we have to um
we have to set up the problem like this
so we just give the problem a name just
so we can keep track of it
and then also set the problem type as
cbc mixed integer programming and that
will mean that we can interface the cbc
back end
so the next thing we have to do is
define these entities which for those
who remember from the lecture slides
i had two of them they were s for
standard product and p for premium
the parameters so the way i typically
write these out is i use dictionaries so
the reason i use dictionaries is that
they can be indexed by name so this
means that we can
index parameters by um
yeah for the relevant entities so we
have for standard the factory build time
was uh check my notes 1.5 hours and for
premium it was
two hours
the profit contribution for standard was
one two five and for
premium it was uh
200 pounds for everything we built and
the total time we have in the factory to
make or this is 40 hours
so the reason i set these up as
dictionaries is that
i can very easily go well what's the
build time for the standard item by just
doing t i and then just using s as the
um
just using s to index it
the next thing we have to do is set up
these variables which
for the standard product it was 10
because we've got that load limit that
we need to make 10
and for the upper bound it is
infinite
and also make sure you name your
variables as well
which is important and give them names
that um make sense
so i'll just call that one yes because
that's exactly why it's indexing
and then exactly the same for the
premium products just the difference is
the lower bound this time is zero we're
not forced to make any of these products
and
then we have name equals y p
so the next thing we have to do is set
the objective value and the way we do
this is i'll show you now with this the
syntax we use is we just effectively use
an inequality
uh sorry not inequality that's for the
constraints but what we just do is we
use something called solver dot sum
so if we remember it was the profit
contribution for each product
multiplied by the amount of products we
make for each product
for i
in
hi
so there we have an objective function
and it's as simple as that to set up
with our tools which again i quite like
the syntax it's very easy to access what
we've got here
is
what we've got here is for hi value
we're just multiplying the profit
contribution multiplied by the amount
that we've made
then the final thing we have to do is we
have to add this capacity constraint
which was uh again we'll use the solder
that's some function to do this um
so we have t i i
multiplied
by y i
i
so that should be the problem set up and
all we need to solve this albeit very
simple linear program so again just to
iterate some of the things i'm using
dictionaries just so that it helps me
index things in the future
and then i'm using the solver.sum
functions to sum over all of the
entities in the problem
oh that's
a
okay so let's reset that
so then you run the solver which is as
simple as using solver.solve
and what you typically get back
hopefully is a value of zero this means
the optimal objective value was found
um but if you get other numbers back
they can
they can mean different things some of
them mean that the problem you've set up
is infeasible there's actually no
feasible solution
which has a different numeric value and
you can look those up on the or tools
website
and there's also things like unbounded
as well so if we haven't set a factory
production limit here for example then
we just make an infinite amount of items
and make infinite profit
but hopefully what we should see is
what we saw on the slide which was that
the optimal solution here
we're making the 10 of the standard
product and then we're making 12 and a
half units we're using the rest of the
factory time to make um the premium
product which is exactly what we saw
when we solved this solution on paper
so that is hopefully a lot potentially a
lot of people's first time they've seen
a linear program solved in python before
um and yeah that's typically the process
i
go around doing but the key thing to
note is that i've got the entities the
parameters the decision variables the
objective values and the constraints
very similar to what we have on paper
just converted into python code
so that is our first linear program
solved
and
i will now start presenting my slides
again
slide
so what we've just seen
is uh
sorry i'm just a couple of slides behind
so we've just seen is that we can get
this optimal objective value from this
problem very
very easily using python code
so now i'm going to move on to something
slightly more complex and potentially in
a few slides time we'll see something
potentially much much more interesting
which is
mixed integer linear programming so this
concerns cases where we no longer have
these continuous variables
so what we've got here is we've got the
exact same problem before but let's add
an extra constraint into the mix here
let's say the supermarket that's buying
our boxes of crisps aren't concerned if
we have a half full box they are only
they will only buy the product off us if
there is a full box that's been made
so what this means is that we have
what's called an integer programming
problem
it's
because the feasible solutions here
don't include these half boxes of crisps
or any fractional box really so we can
see on the slides is that these are
shown by the black points here
now this actually makes problems much
more interesting and also means that
um
that linear programming
isn't as applicable as it was before
because what we can see on this slide
here is that the
optimal solution for the linear
programming problem was very easy to
find it was just a corner of the search
space
but the optimal solution here it's a bit
difficult to tell just from this slide
whether it's the one that's the very top
left and that's just below the optimal
linear
solution or it could be one of these
ones that's closer along the edge as
well might actually give you a better
objective value
now this is might seem quite subtle this
is an important point that
this conversion from um
linear of continuous values to integer
values it's
fairly trivial to write on paper but
actually it means that the solver
actually has to work much much harder in
the back end to solve this kind of
problem
and the reason this is the case is that
rather than yeah using one of these
simplex algorithms i mentioned earlier
the um
the solver what it has to do is it
actually has to branch the search space
into lots of different sub branches
effectively i'm not going to huge amount
of detail here but the key to remember
is when you start introducing integers
into your
decision variables
it means that the problem might take
much much longer to solve just because
the solver just has to work so much
harder and do much more clever things to
actually find a solution
but the good news for us is that as data
scientists when we write the code
it's a fairly trivial change to make
which i'm going to show now in the
notebook again that it's literally a
case of changing a couple of lines in
your code and you'll find
the optimal decision
decision variables for these
for these integer problems so i'm going
to do that now and what you'll hopefully
see is that
yes the solver potentially will be
working much harder in the back end with
a problem like this but
we can write code
very cleanly that will solve these as um
very simple in a very similar way
certainly on the front end when looking
at the code so
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
make a small change to the previous
linear program and find the optimal
value of um of this problem and i'm
going to show you guys how you can do it
so let's uh
let's open my
notebook again
powerpoint seems to have taken over my
entire screen
let's quit that
okay
so if my notebook's um now being shared
uh
yeah begins here
perfect
so because we've got quite a short um
because we've got quite a
short session today
i'm going to
uh
just copy the solution we had before but
show you how we can make this into a
integer
problem
which is as you can see as simple as
doing this
so before we had these num bars now
we're just going to have these into bars
and we're hopefully going to see
something interesting about the solution
as well when we do this
so now let's set up the solver let's run
through it let's get a solution
and
let's
let's see what the
optimum value is
so this is something that's very very
important in integer programming
so before the optimal solution was to
make 10 of the standard products and 12
and a half of the premium product
whereas here the optimal solution is to
make
12 of the standard products and 11 of
the premium products and this highlights
something important
um which when you read in the literature
actually is quite common and it's why
integer programming is
kind of important is that
the
optimum solution to an integer
programming problem isn't necessarily
going to be the vertex that's closest to
the corner
because if that was the case what we'd
have here is
um
we'd have uh we'd be making
10 of the standard pro again and just 12
of the premium products but in this case
that doesn't maximize the objective
values better to sacrifice
some of the or at least one of the
premium product values because you can
then fit in a couple more standard
products that you can make
so that's
yeah that's basically it really on this
side this is the most simple use of
integer programming is when you've got
numeric variables that are forced to
take integer
values
so that is uh the end of that i think
now is a good time to take a couple more
questions if there's any
coming
in yeah we have three questions uh yeah
so two of them are about right so first
question is like can we pass options to
limit the solving time in case of very
difficult milp programs
and does it
work well and returns the best valid
solution so far
yes exactly this is a really important
point that i actually didn't have in my
um
in my
slides today but certainly
what often happens is you do get such a
huge problem that getting the optimal
value isn't
often the best thing you want to do just
because it'll take so long and
there is syntax which i haven't used in
quite a while actually but it's usually
typically syntax that you're using the
backend solver so you have to pass
arguments to
our tools and what it does is exactly as
was mentioned it'll give you the best
solution that you have so far
um and yeah that's
and that's um
when i mentioned earlier that when you
run these solvers you get these numeric
values back that you get a zero one two
three
um
one of the numbers does correspond to um
feasible solution that's the best we
found so far but isn't the guaranteed
optimal
thank you and
the next question is does the zohar tool
support a warm start and that is to say
like passing an initial guess to the
solver to speed it up somewhat
um
i'm not sure i've never seen this before
um
[Music]
so so things like warm starts are
typically
more associated with heuristic solving
methods which are effectively
ways of going through your search space
that
that are
and that aren't guaranteed to get your
best solution um i've never seen
anything like a warm stein linear
programming noir tools before but i
might be wrong so i wouldn't know how to
do that because i've not seen anything
like that before
thank you and the last question is is it
possible to index entities over a
product offset
uh yeah you can structure your code
however you want this is just my own
preference how i've done it but
yeah absolutely you can um do it as just
suggested you can build your sets using
whatever syntax you prefer
all right thank you thank you for
answering these three uh we do not have
any others at the moment okay cool well
now i'm gonna talk about
something much more
exciting hopefully
um to me anyway but i might just be a
bit boring
which is
where i think uh mixed integer linear
programming really comes into its own
uh so yeah so we've just done that
previous slide so now i'm going to talk
about a problem statement that's been
changed ever so slightly
and
this is what the problem statement is is
that the factory in the previous example
says it can make more profit by
manufacturing boxes of what we'll call
extra premium crisps
it takes two and a half hours of factory
time to make a box of these but the
profit contribution is much bigger 275
pounds but there is a problem that to
manufacture them we need to hire an
extra machine in our factory that we
don't currently have access to
so the question is should the factory be
altering
our production strategy so it's kind of
a trade-off here is is the hiring of
this extra machine worthwhile for us
but this this should be ringing alarm
bells to anybody who wants to build a
linear program
and in particular it's um
it's to do with the higher extra machine
um because what it's doing is this is
somewhere in your problem where you have
a non-linearity that linear programming
will not be able to solve
because
um what you've got is if you hire this
machine you could make
one box of extra premium crisps or you
could make a thousand of them but that
cost is still 500 pounds to the factory
so
yeah this is where we've got something
that's much much more complicated to
solve and this is where for me these are
the kind of problems that i love solving
within mixed integer lydia programming
and i've solved quite a few problems
like this before
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
walk through the previous examples uh
slides and show you how we can introduce
another decision variable that can solve
this problem for us and we can still use
at least mixed integer linear
programming
so
um
if i walk through the previous problem
we had
we described the constraints and
objectives they're exactly the same as
we had before
but the difference we have here is that
we've got this extra thing if we make
any any extra premium crisp we'll incur
a startup cost of 500 pounds which is
it's a fixed cost no matter how many of
these extra premium crisps we make
so let's go through the process again
we'll define the entities of sets
the entity
is the easiest thing to fix because you
just add one extra entity into the
problem
the parameters again because we had two
now we have three we just have an extra
build time and an extra profit margin
but the i'm also introducing something
called m which i'm not gonna mention
until the very end of this slide because
you'll see what it does in any in about
two minutes time
the decision variables again they look
very very similar the only difference
being that we have one extra entity um
for y
but we also have something called delta
which is there to keep track of whether
or not we need to hire this machine
so delta what it does is it um yeah it
should be forced to have the value zero
if we don't need to hire the machine and
one if we do
so how do we use this delta value well
firstly let's think about the objective
function
we've got again this very very similar
objective function with the profits
but this time we add something in which
is minus 500 times delta
so just to go through exactly why it
looks like this
if delta is zero that means we haven't
hired this machine so 500 times delta in
this case is zero
if delta is one we have hide the machine
so that means we're imposing a 500 pound
penalty to the objective function only
if we hire that machine
but the key question here is how do we
make sure that delta has the right value
for the problem at hand and how do we
force it to take the correct value
and this is how we do this
so what i've set up is we've got the
exact same constraints as we had before
but this time we have one extra part
component to it which is
m times delta is greater than or equal
to y e
so let's think about the two different
scenarios we might have in this problem
the first one
is that we don't make any extra premium
crisps so that means y e is zero
in this case we have this big m value
times delta it's got to be greater than
or equal to zero so this delta can
actually take zero or one in this case
and in the optimal case it's not going
to take the value one if that machine's
not used because that's just an imposed
cost that doesn't wouldn't be doing
anything
but now let's consider even the most
conservative case where we have
um
y e we just make one box of these extra
premium crisps even in this case where
we make very very few
what we've got is m times delta has got
to be greater than or equal to one so
this means in this case delta cannot
take the value
zero it is forced to take the value one
and this is where lin mixed into linear
programming it becomes so powerful
because
this is now going beyond the realms of
being able to just solve a simple linear
problem we can actually introduce
decisions and these binary decisions in
particular are
really what makes um yeah
the problems we can solve with integer
programming much much more interesting
and
i'm now going to go through this exact
problem um in the lecture problems now
and i'm going to
yes see whether or not it's worthwhile
hiring this extra machine so i'm going
to re-um go into the
i'm going to the notebooks again
so i should now be sharing my screen
again and i should be
we should be able to start coding up
this slightly more complicated problem
so what we've got is um
[Music]
the entities in this case are s
p
and e
the parameters um
similar to last time we just got these
extra ones so we've got s
um as before we've got uh 1.5 we've got
for the premium it's
two hours of build time and then for
extra premium it's 2.5
hours the profit margins are for s
125 for p
200 and for
e
we have
two seven five
factory build time in total again 40
hours
and uh yeah ce is what i'm going to call
the cost of hiring extra machine if we
need it which i'm going to call which is
500 pounds
so for s we've got the lower bound of 10
units which is the same as what we had
before i'm going to set the upper bound
as infinite again and name equals
1 y s
we have low bound equals zero
y
p
and then again we can have another
decision variable for y at this stage
there's nothing more complicated it just
looks exactly the same as it does for
premium um
which will look like this
name equals y
e
then the final thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to introduce this delta
variable which we can see is also an
integer this time it can only take the
values
0 or 1 so we can do that using these
lower bounds and
upper bounds equals 1
and i'm just going to call it delta
the objective function is uh going to be
um
let me just check my own notes
but it should be very similar to what we
had before just with this delta
component added so we're going to use
the solver.sum
part again then we have pi
times says the profit multiplied by the
amount we make
i in
i
and then the only difference here is
we're going to impose this penalty which
is effectively going to be 500 pounds
times delta
and the final thing is we're going to
have the same constraints as before for
the factory build part of it which is
the 40 hour limit
and which you can see is going to be t i
i multiplied by y i
i
for i in i
that's going to be less than or equal to
t
and then the final thing is we've got to
really keep track of this delta variable
and make sure it has the right value for
us
so that's going to be m times
delta
uh if we remember the
formulation
it was
um m times delta is greater than or
equal to
y i
e
so if we if this y value is ever um
so just to reiterate if this y value is
ever non-zero then this constraint means
that delta has to equal one
and there we go if you just set up
another linear solver that hopefully
will give us a solution here we go and
we see the solution's exactly the same
as it was before so that is telling us
that the um
that the this extra cost of hiring the
machine is not worth it so the answer is
no this factory should not be changing
its production strategy
based on the inclusion of this
yeah based on the inclusion of his extra
premium
crisp where potentially
penn state might yield more money yes
but um the factory higher cost of the
extra machine isn't worth it so what
we've just gone through is three really
simple things and hopefully the last
one's the really important one is that
where we've introduced an integer that's
really doing an interesting
part of the problem which is modeling a
binary decision and if you've got these
binary decisions in your linear
programming then this tells you that
mixed integer programming is also
might also be applicable to your problem
so
that's the
end of the sort of lecture slides part
of today's um presentation
um so i guess now would probably be a
good time to take more questions if any
are
forthcoming
um i don't see any questions on the chat
right now
okay if anyone wants to please your
questions
yeah i guess we could uh just carry on
with the very last part i'm going to go
through with the last 10 minutes and
then at the end uh have any questions as
well
so
yeah what i'm going to talk a little bit
about now is the um
the repo that i put together which
should be um
should be of interest to people here who
found this presentation interesting
hopefully so the repo also has something
called
uh problems in it and what i've got in
here is i've got a
um
problem about um
the location of facilities for a company
so
this hope has been designed in such a
way this notebook where it gives people
a chance to um
[Music]
to
model potentially slightly more
complicated problem using integer
programming
um i'm not going to actually type
through the code now because
um because we don't really have the time
but i might actually show you the
solution and some of highlight a few
things to what i do to solve this
problem
so the first thing i want to do is
actually i'll talk a little bit about
the problem itself that you'll
potentially be solving in this notebook
if you've got an interest in this kind
of work
it is that a large company wishes to
move some of its departments out of
london
and there are benefits to doing this
to the company
they have five departments called abcd
and e
and the possible cities for the
relocation of bristol and brighton which
actually isn't very helpful because both
of those begin with the same three
letters so when you're trying to put
together your
sets of entities uh it gets a bit
confusing but i just call the cities by
their full names for that reason and
then there's a benefit derived
from each relocation
and
one of the um
things i do is in this notebook it gives
you a chance to go through this six
stage process that i mentioned earlier
to firstly describe the rules and the
constraints verbally
then to describe the entities to write
them down in your notebook and then
write them down
in the python code style that i prefer
or any style you prefer
um the parameters are these benefits
matrices
um work out your decision variables and
uh find your objective function and find
your solution
now this well the first part the way
i've designed this notebook is there's a
first part which is relatively simple
and it's basically as long as you have a
good grasp of
these binary decision variables which
are effectively just keeping track of
where each department is located
you'll be able to solve this
quite easily but also there's a second
part of the problem which is actually
the one that's taken from the notebook
where they introduce something called
communications costs and
i won't go through the solution because
it is on the
github repo but this is something that
where you have to introduce what i would
call a linear programming or integer
programming trick to the problem to
solve it
because what you end up doing is when i
first formulated this problem is i had a
case where there were
two binary decision variables that were
multiplied together and that's not great
because
you then have a non-linearity but what
you can do is you can actually
use a trick here which is um
written in this hint
to effectively force a third decision
variable to have the value one
only in the case where both of the delta
variables are one and you do that by
introducing these three constraints
so
hopefully when if people do have time to
go through this or are interested in
going through this they'll see this
trick in action and they'll hopefully
get a real understanding of um when we
can do some really really interesting
things with mixed integer linear
programming but as we only have 15
minutes left i would suggest that this
is a um exercise that hopefully people
can do in their own time if they have an
interest in it
and um
yeah at this stage i think i'll because
we only have 15 minutes left i think
i'll probably say my closing remarks
about today's session
and then hopefully take any questions if
any of those are forth coming so let me
reopen my slides
and let's
go through
the
yeah some closing remarks from me which
hopefully will be very useful to people
here if not i yeah again i'm not a huge
expert in linear programming and mixed
interest programming but
this is you know my own um
thoughts
from
doing this for a couple of years
so the first thing i want to say which
is hopefully
going to be a really important thing for
people here is that these mathematical
optimization problems are actually super
common businesses
and in particular any problem that
requires us to allocate resources in
some way can be modeled in this kind of
way
so some classic optimization problems
that you might see include things like
facilities so this is an interesting one
for us as a supermarket because it's
where should i put my facilities to
best serve my customers
so this is something a classic problem
that's called the facility location
problem
um staffing where should i put members
of staff and how many do i need and this
is really where the first problems in
linear programming were solved in this
space
the third and third interesting problem
to consider is anything to do with
resource allocation which is what we've
been talking about today so if i've got
a limited budget either a factory time
budget or budget to buy things what
should i spend my time doing or what
should i buy in to maximize revenue
then finally the most probably one of
the most classic
optimization problems is vehicle routing
where should i
um where should i send my vans or my um
[Music]
or my
cars or anything like this to visit the
most places and maximize
the most
uh yeah do run my operation most
efficiently now the reason i've
highlighted these four problems is that
what i've found over the past few years
is that even though um problems can come
in so many different flavors and have
slightly different um
sorry different
um
things that go into them
really a lot of them are covered by
these kind of basic problems or
extensions of these basic problems
and there's so many cases in business
that i've seen even in my year and a
half to two years just studying these
things where
optimization problems are just come up
and you know you can actually solve them
using things like linear programming and
mixed integer linear programming and my
own experience in the past year has been
that i've been working on a problem that
has a prediction element then you want
to pick an optimal set from your
predictions
so yeah i guess
my key point here is that these are
really wide-ranging problems and there's
a lot of problems out there that can be
solved using the techniques that i've
talked about today
and yeah i think having a knowledge of a
what these problems are and b what kind
of open source tools you can actually
use to solve these without paying
anything for commercial solvers can
really help um your team and you can
potentially start solving really really
interesting problems
the second thing i'd like to say to
close is that
i've talked through this six or seven
stage process i often remain guilty i
have to say of trying to rush ahead and
build linear programs before going
through these but
you know as i've mentioned very early on
these programs are very very specific in
their format and going through this six
stage process or seven stage with the
iteration
has helped me vastly in the past year or
so and the more disciplined i've got
about that the better my
building of linear programming has got
and by building this program step by
step on paper first you'll really start
to get some
interesting insights to the problem at
hand as well and really start to
understand what's going on in your
problem
and then finally the last thing i want
to say is that
just keep learning about these problems
if they interest you there are lots of
these small tricks and changes you can
make in your linear programs and your
mixed integer linear programs to make
them much more flexible often much
faster as well just by re changing
something
in the formulation and things like this
so
you know if you think you've got a
problem that potentially either can't be
solved for linear programming or
potentially
is going to be very slow
there are often things you can change to
make them much faster and much much more
flexible and for me there are so many
problems that can be solved in this way
if you just have try and keep your mind
as flexible as possible in terms of
trying to introduce these integer
decision variables for example to make
everything much much more um
yeah which basically means that you can
just solve so many different things but
yeah that's all i'm going to say today
and again please take a look at the
notebooks if you want to solve a
potentially much more complex linear
programming or mixed integer
linear programming problem and the last
thing i want to say is that
we at tesco are hiring data scientists
at the moment um
so if you are interested in potentially
working at tesco and working on some
interesting problems mentioned the very
start of today's presentation then yeah
we're hiring for senior positions in
typical machine learning problems but
also computer vision time series
forecasting and we also have a
presentation tomorrow by
um yeah our head of data engineering too
he'll be talking about a much wider
scope of the kind of data science we do
here at tesco
but uh yeah you can send me a message if
you forget what these names are um or
yeah keep making notes of them and
that's charlotte cooper 11 is our
recruiter but we'll also you can just
send an email to data science at
tesco.com
if you know you think they've found
today's presentation interesting or you
potentially want to come and work here
then
yeah we have positions available but
that is all i'm going to say today
because i feel like i've been talking
for quite a while now and hopefully that
leaves us with a few minutes for
questions if they come in
thank you so much for the
amazing session ross we do have some
questions
so i'll
shoot them away so first one is bike
rack and i guess this was answered a bit
uh but i guess this specifically dives
into what you do so the question is what
are the typical real world lp pro
problems that you encounter at your work
so
yeah so for me in so i can answer that
on sort of two stages i think firstly
for the work that tesco do
it's very much mostly what a lot of big
companies do which is things like
optimizing
vehicle routing for example is probably
the biggest area in a company like tesco
as it would also be in amazon and any
other big business really
but also for me i've been working on um
[Music]
a predict optimized problem in pricing
as well we're not gonna go into the
details of exactly
what goes into the back end of that but
um
in a pricing problem that i've been
looking at we've
yeah you effectively
we have a prediction element to it which
is to effectively try and predict price
elasticity and then do an optimization
to decide what the optimal price can be
so
yeah pricing is also an interesting area
for these kind of problems
thank you for the answer
we have the next question but corning
and
so the question is maybe you have
mentioned this already but is there a
way to extract the marginal values
uh what's
the marginal
sorry can i just repeat that question
yeah so is there a way to extract the
marginal values i'm not sure if
that's the question
okay
if you want you can uh unmute yourself
and maybe elaborate
more on the question
uh yes so uh i think also the the
question relates to the question that
was asked after me as so
one of the things okay can you hear me
by the way
yes yes i can all right
so the marginal values i mean what
happens if um
for example constraint uh slightly
changes how did you go from
like in your example at the the effects
reproduction limit if it goes to 41.
um how does that alter your result that
that's what i mean with the marginal
values yes yes
uh so i do actually have an answer to
that is yes you can in a linear program
actually
um and
there's a
i haven't ever done any of this
but you can certainly extract this
information and what these are called in
linear programming is often called
shadow pricing it's called i think which
effectively yeah it tells you how your
objective
and your solution would change um
if a constraint
was to change slightly
now my understanding having
read around this subject very briefly is
that
it is very very limited in scope so
what i mean by this is that
so in the problem we talked about today
um
it would be um
you'd probably be able to do that
infinitely because we only really had
this one factory production constraints
and if you kept increasing that
everything's going to increase
effectively linearly but
what typically happens is in a linear
program you'll have lots and lots of
constraints that are all working in a
in slightly different directions
effectively and
what these marginal values will do is
they'll only really tell you what will
change what will change if
a particular bounding constraint changes
slightly because the issue you usually
face when you build a really complicated
linear program is that the constraint
that's actually bounding your problem
will change if that makes sense i don't
know
explain this so so my question really
relates to uh oh our tools yes
[Music]
so i'm very aware of of of shadow prices
and like
no analysis and that you solve the the
basically look at the dual of the of the
lp
yeah like that so i'm specifically
interested in how to extract these
values from our tools
ah okay um
the answer is i've never done it
um
so i can't really give you an answer my
understanding is that
you can
because i'm sure i've read about it but
again i
wouldn't be able to give you a firm
answer to that of how easy it is to do
it
so i'm not going to even attempt to give
a more complicated answer than that
right yes thank you very much
thank you and this also answers the next
question by moritz and uh
on the same lines
so we have one more question by courtney
so is it
i guess this is a different question so
is it possible to connect with one of
the common solvers and examples given uh
cpl ex and the roby
yes
so um you can change the back end solver
quite easily in
our tools and they do have support for
as far as i could see there were two
that were definitely mentioned yes but
also c plex and any other solvers can
also be interfaced
it's just a case of changing the
argument when you set up the solver
all right uh so this is all of the
questions that we have right now if no
one has any other questions uh maybe we
can end this session
so yeah thank you so much for this
amazing session i like i i i and i guess
everyone here enjoyed it and yeah thank
you so much for being here and enjoy the
rest of your conference
you